now by mo lee who was attacked by him 40
years ago
uh thank you very much for being with us
as i say you were attacked in
1980 just tell us what happened if you
can that night in leeds
um i was just walking home after a
saturday night i was out with friends
planning my 21st birthday party
and i took a shortcut through the
university grounds in leeds
and in that road there was a light out
and i carried on walking
towards woodhouse lane towards the main
road
i heard a voice from behind saying hey
you
hi how are you i thought it's bound to
be someone i know
so i turned around i stopped in my
tracks and i turned around
and i uh approached a young man
i thought you must know me he's really
friendly very light voice very friendly
and then as i got closer i realized i
didn't know him so i turned around and
carried on walking and i thought this
isn't good i can hear
his footsteps behind me
and i sense danger and then i
started to run on his footsteps got
faster and faster and as i started to
run faster and faster
it increased and before i knew i had a
massive whack
to the top of my head and i just saw the
pavement coming towards me
and i blanked down and that was the
the last you remember until you you woke
up in in hospital i mean so he hit you
with a hammer is that right and and so
when did you realize yes as it turns out
yeah go carry on carry on he repeatedly
hit me over the head with a hammer
absolutely look he's lucky to be here
yeah absolutely terrifying so when did
you realize that the attacker was
sutcliffe well he was caught
the attack was in the october and in the
new year he was caught
and his face came on camera and i'd seen
that young man
and i knew deep down it was him
when i saw his face on the tv newsreel
and when did the police accept it was
him and
interview him and so forth
well i'm very sad to say they didn't
accept my attack
because it was airbrushed out because
they were seen to be
not conducting themselves in the way
that they should by
not catching this serial killer they
ignored my description my
explanation and decided to just
move on so i was airbrushed out of the
investigation
up until 1996
when chief constable keith hallowell
knew about he'd read the byford report
and he saw
my name there and he wanted to interview
sutcliffe
and and did and tried to get him to
confess but he didn't
he did confess to another a couple of
attacks
but not mine i mean that's just awful
we'll talk about the police in just a
moment but 40 years on
he is dead what are your thoughts about
that
well it doesn't really change anything
it doesn't change history
it just means that he's no longer on the
planet
and i think some of us might feel that
they've been cheated
from the final chance of getting a
confession from him but i knew all along
he would never confess
it was his way of having control over
the forgotten victims like myself
and my heart goes out to all the other
families
who are having to witness all this over
again this mythology of
the yorkshire ripper the same old
coverage um but i've written a book to
try and redress the balance on that
and tell it from a survivor's side as an
artist
and a writer to kind of shed
much better light on on on the narrative
around this
yeah it's interesting because what do
you think of the way
he has been portrayed i mean some say
the very name
yorkshire ripper simply glorifies what
he did in a sense
well i think he mythologizes him and put
him puts him in a very high status
but he was just an ordinary lorry driver
and what we have to ask ourselves now is
why how did he come to exist with this
trait
to want to kill and maim brutally maim
women
what was it in our society that that
didn't see that coming
what was it in our society that didn't
prevent that
and what was it within the the
misogynistic
um prevailing attitude at the time
why why was that allowed to happen i
mean i know things are different now but
i think we have there's a lot of
questions to be asked
and you were asked to draw a portrait of
him
some years later for a documentary uh mo
well why bro art film yes why
why did you want to do that well this
iconic photograph of suck cliff in his
bow tie
looking jolly you know in his wedding
garb
and it every time i saw it it was really
quite frightening
to be fair because it took me back and i
thought it must take other people back
so i drew it you know as realistically
as
the image would give me um and then
i'm filmed ripping up the ripper
and and just tearing his identity apart
and the pig the pieces fall to the floor
and i walk over the fragments of his
face
and it just seemed like a really good
way
to end my encounters with seeing that
that picture and it's in the last
chapter of my book
but mo i mean that must have been an
incredibly hard thing to do
to sit there and draw
the man who attacked you and murdered so
many others
well it was but i'd had some extremely
good
schema conditioning therapy by the
speakmans
and that reframed the way i thought
about what had happened and it reframed
the way i saw that image
and it was very empowering uh
but when you when you draw something you
objectify it
and i it was stopping me from being
objectified
as as a mention as a a ripper victim and
i just turned the tables and objectified
him it was very
very satisfying yeah and just finally
um just your well i suppose your final
thoughts
on this man
well he was human but he didn't have any
humanity
i i don't think he had any any
attributes at all but what we need to do
is to ask why
he came into existence but i have no
feelings
no okay in terms of
i'm i'm sorry for the other um
for the other other survivors i'm
desperately sad for the
families of lost loved ones but in terms
as a human
i'm not really prepared to invest in any
any thoughts on him as a person though
okay molly look we appreciate you
telling your story
it can't be easy but thank you very much
indeed
you're welcome thank you